the thing that people don't understand
is that
um women go through something called
menopause
it's been known i mean i heard about it
when i was in my 20s obviously
most most people men inclusive have
heard about it i didn't hear the term
andropause until i don't know recently
like in the last five or ten years or so
and that's the male version of menopause
menopause hits women very quickly
because
they stop dropping eggs and their
endocrine system changes and they get
the hot flashes
and in some cases women have to have a
hysterectomy and there's all kinds of
um things and complications that pop up
but it's an overnight thing
so medical science is very attentive to
that
and they have been for quite some time
um the clinic that i use to manage my
endocrine system
whenever i've been there in the past
before covet lockdowns and all that sort
of stuff
it's primarily been women so anybody
that tries to shame you for doing this
guys
oh you know all this sort of like all
the narratives they'll try to throw at
you
it's it's mostly women using these
clinics still uh there's not a lot of
guys that use it and all the guys that
are fully aware of it but andropause is
is a problem because what ends up
happening is your testosterone levels
will peak
around the age of 25 to 30 for most guys
if you're healthy
and then after about 25 30 they'll start
to decline by about one percent per year
uh basically until you're dead so
somewhere between one to two percent per
year your
your t levels will drop naturally which
is which is fine it's it's
absolutely um you know part of the aging
process
but the problem is you don't really
notice it and a lot of guys
will start to complain by their late 30s
or 40s in some cases 50s even
depending on how their endocrine
system's working
they feel depressed they've got mental
fog their libido suffers
erection quality suffers uh productivity
suffers
there's all kinds of problems that come
with low t
body fat you know muscle wasting
obviously you know you're going to
accumulate more more body fat you're
going to muscle
you've got a muscle waste and all that
sort of stuff
and trt in therapeutic doses
and when i'm talking about therapeutic
dosages guys i'm not talking about
bolus ass bodybuilder doses like way up
in the stratosphere
i'm talking about therapeutic levels
that really just
top you up to where you were when you
were 30. okay
that's that's really the point of
testosterone replacement therapy
it's very very different from athletic
use
there are some guys that will get
athletic results because they're hyper
responders
to a therapeutic dose of trt
it's strange i was watching this video
um the other day
and i'm going to dispense some resources
you know for you guys as well
you know channels that i think that you
should check out that i've followed as
well but
um a they they basically dose a bunch of
guys
i think it was 40 or something like that
in 125
250 and 500 milligram per week dosages
um and there's hyper responders in each
group
so you could have on 125 milligram dose
per week which is
essentially a therapeutic dose uh be a
hyper responder
and have blood blood serum levels at
like 3 000 nanograms per deciliter which
is huge
essentially most most bodybuilders will
be in that range because you're a hyper
responder and your body
reacts very very well to it other guys
125 milligrams per week will do almost
nothing for them
so it's it's a bit of an edgy science
and if i'm being honest you can't really
trust
your medical practitioner to do the
right thing for you because a lot of
them really don't know what they're
doing
um i get really nerdy and geeky
on stuff that i'm interested in i've
always been that way will always be that
way when it comes to cars shopping for
cars
uh anything with with self-care i'm i'm
fastidious about it you know when it
comes to sleep like i spend a lot of
money
on a mattress on a chili pad which cools
a pad
excuse me and all that stuff just
because
it's super important me so i of course
do all the research and
you know the uh the studying behind it
i'm gonna have to drink some here
[ __ ]
choking up too damn hot this tea right
now
let that cool down but um
yeah you can't rely on
as as weird as it sounds you can't rely
on a
um medical practitioner to always do the
right thing
one of the things that i've noticed
being part of some uh facebook groups
that that have trt discussions in them
and join some i mean just search on
facebook you know for trt and you know
you'll be able to join you can see what
the discussions are
um the standard dose seems to be like
like the cookie cutter dose is
the guy doesn't feel good all right
we'll give him 200 milligrams a week
uh a ai which stands for a aromatized
inhibitor
which i'll talk about a little bit more
and go have some fun
and um it's it's no wonder you see guys
in there you know complaining about
things like back knee
um you know they get accelerated hair
loss um
you know anger mood issues and and and
stuff like
that because they're they're just using
a cookie cutter treatment for
you know a lot of these guys and
telemedicine
you know is one of the ways they
dispense this so
if i'm being honest you need to take
ownership for how you feel
and what your treatment regime looks
like
i've seen them do really really dumb
things like a licensed medical
practitioner a freaking doctor that went
to school
will encourage you to do a
once a week shot or in some cases i've
even seen some some guys say that you
know
i have to go into the medical uh
facility and they inject me once every
two weeks
which is insane to load up a
syringe like this which is probably
going to be a three milligame
gram dose a full dose like that every
two weeks
is going to give you a big huge spike in
your testosterone levels
and you're going to feel crazy probably
within about 36 to 48 hours
and then it's just going to go on the
decline after that until it goes up in a
big spike again
and that's not how your body produces
testosterone your body
like like you're going as your balls
will produce somewhere between 7 to 15
milligrams per day
so why would you go in and throw in like
200 milligrams into your body
over the course of two weeks and then go
back again and do that again in two
weeks and have these huge roller coaster
rides up and down
when your body's doing this every day to
make sure that you've got
steady levels and then some medical
clinic
comes along and says yeah yeah you know
you got low t come in we'll do the shots
for you here's an ai and this
boom you know they gave him like a huge
bullish shot he's like boom
36 hours later he feels like a
bodybuilder and then you know 10 days
into it he feels like crap again
so you've really got to take ownership
for it
um even to this day on my
um bottles it says inject .25 mil
as directed two times a weekly now i
started out
on that regime and just to give you some
frame
and i'm i'm seeing the super chats come
in so i'm gonna deal with those in a
second i'll take a little break to take
some of them
um so i started out with
using basically a needle like this and i
don't know if you can see that but
that's a one inch needle
that's not what the doctor gave me to
start injected with i got a one and a
half inch needle
and basically the way that it works is
you draw with this one
from the bottle because it's a 23 gauge
you unscrew the cap you put in
a 25 gauge one and a half inch then you
inject into your glutes
gluteus maximus you know the doctors
will say it's a big target it's easy to
hit you can't miss it there's not a lot
of nerve endings in it
just as long as you go up in the upper
quadrant you'll be fine holy [ __ ] did
that hurt
and within about a week a week and a
half i was like this is insane this is
not sustainable you cannot you know put
an inch and a half
of metal in your butt cheek twice a week
for the rest of your life because once
you're on it i mean
you're like it's a lifetime protocol you
don't really stop so
i did them let's do the math again right
so you're going twice a week so there's
52 weeks of 52 times 2 so that's 104
shots
per year let's assume i live another 30
or 40 let's call it 35 years
sometimes 35 years you're putting 3640
holes in your butt cheeks now you know
you can divide that by two because
obviously you alternate left to right
sort of thing
but you're gonna develop a lot of scar
tissue and
that's gonna be problematic so i went
looking for answers i mean like
you know most medical shops will just
give the guys
a package and say go home this is how
you do it and it's like how is that
sustainable for
the rest of your life so i found smarter
guys on the internet
and i started to realize that there's a
backfilling process
so i'll explain that to you so this is
an insulin needle this is what
um you'll get diabetics using typically
um
because it's used generally speaking to
push water through it
so it doesn't need to be as big whereas
testosterone's oil
base so you need a bigger needle and a
bigger plunger to push it
this is what it looks like by the way i
mean if this is a new one i have to
use this one next because i'm almost out
but it's a
little tiny bottle like this and that's
all that it looks like it's a tiny
little thing okay and it's got this
yellowish colored oil in it
okay the oil is the ester and the
testosterone is basically
i'm going to butcher the description how
this works but the testosterone
is connected to the ester and the ester
delays
the release in your bloodstream now
this is considered bioidentical hormone
replacement all that means is the
testosterone molecule
is identical to what your gonads make
so your body doesn't know the difference
anyway
so that's the so that's the product so
the system that they're gonna offer you
is gonna be our cake it's not gonna be
comfortable it's it's gonna be painful
in fact and it's not gonna make a lot of
sense but there's smarter guys on the
internet that i found
when i was looking for injection sites
how to inject
and i came across this concept called
backfilling and all that is is you draw
and fill up
you know your needle here so let's say
you know you're gonna put in your three
milligrams and
you're going to store this in the needle
for a week or two or you know like
whatever length of time it takes you to
finish it and then you take your insulin
needle
pop out the plunger and then you
backfill
from in here until you get your i
i do uh 10 iu every other every other
day
okay which is not a lot 10 iu is like
that bottom line over there i don't know
if you can see the lines but it's
right at the very bottom and it's just
one line it's not much at all
okay and that i can inject
pretty much anywhere in my body
pain-free you can inject into your belly
fat all you do is you just grab i'm just
going to come back a little bit over
here
all you do is you come back a little bit
and you grab a little bit of fat on your
belly
and you push it between your fingers
also
let me show you the difference you know
between these two pins
keep in mind this is a this is an inch
long the one the doctors gave me to
begin with
they wanted me to use an inch and a half
pin which is what i use for the
first few times so the big one that's
what they started me off with
the little one is what i figured out i
can get oil into my body with
big difference right way smaller way
less scar tissue
almost no pain very convenient doesn't
take long
the backfilling method is the way to go
so if you're on trt right now
just do some searching on youtube on how
to backfill
and do more frequent pins because
ideally you want to mimic the release
in your body the way that your body
produces testosterone not these giant
bolus dosage
36 hours later when it's fully released
in your system you're like
bodybuilder dose basically and then you
got to wait a week or two
and then it tailors off so i put a
little amount in
every other day the reason why it's
every other day testosterone is because
there's another product called hcg human
chorionic gonotropin
and i'll explain that a little bit but
staying on the topic of tea that's what
that is so
we've covered um administration
people have asked about other
administration methods like
pellets creams compounded creams gels
there's nasal sprays most of them
are more expensive not as not as
effective and you can't adjust so
for example pellets so i know some guys
that are on pellets
what they do is they make a small
incision in your
butt in your glute and then they'll
basically put these things that are
about the size of tic tacs
um a few of them in i'm not sure what
the count is and then they stitch you
back up
so you've got exposure to infection they
have you know it's minor surgery i mean
it's a
probably a single stitch it's not that
big of a deal and then the idea is these
things kind of like dissolve in your
body over time and you only need to get
this minor surgery every
i don't know what it is three four six
months whatever the frequency is and
that's it
but the problem with that is you can't
control the release of it
uh your body may not respond the way
that you want to it to
the release of it and you're also
relying on the medical practitioner to
perform this
surgery every time so is it really
practical to go and cut your
glute with a small incision every four
to six months or whatever the frequency
is
i don't think so i think that's a dumb
way to do it i'd rather use a tiny
little pin like this
which you can put anywhere in your body
my favorite injection site is the
ventral glute so again if you're on trt
look up how to inject ventral glute it's
painless
it can take a lot of oil if you're going
with larger dosages there's
there's no nerve endings there there's
it's it's the easiest way to go about it
i sometimes rotate into
subcutaneous which basically isn't a fat
so there's intramuscular im which is in
a muscle
and there's subcutaneous which is in a
fat so i can put it in a belly fat i
don't have a lot of belly
fat but that's one place that you can
put it um you can do shallow injections
in your glute as well so it's another
place you can put it
it's a little harder to push the oil
through a 30 gauge needle this is 30
gauge 5 8
so you do have to push a little harder
but ooh big
deal who cares i'm a guy i've got some
muscle in my hand you just push you know
it's just
about applying some leverage to it
um let me catch up on some of these
super chats so i don't lose some of
these because this is
this is probably going to go on for a
bit to cover here
uh renegade wingman pay attention class
rc's always drop top quality gems
be well thanks bro um our
ak spartan says recently heard about tom
got ali and f
doga arrest this from andrew huberman on
joe rogan have you heard anything yes i
have
so let's talk about that since you
brought it sorry i should put these up
on the screen
um tonga ali is proven to work
um i've used it but while i'm on trt
it's kind of pointless i mean i had a
guy that wanted to sponsor me and he
sent me a sample of it i'm like
it tastes like [ __ ] because it was like
in this spoon
um but does it work scientifically yeah
it's it's proven to work you can
you can probably boost your um nanogram
per deciliter level by about 100 to 200
points so if you're at three or four
hundred and you're feeling low and
shitty
tongat ali will probably boost it up 100
to 200 points
there's another one called fedoga
orestes which i think he's uh spelled
correctly if i'm not mistaken
and that's also supposed to work
although it's not as well researched and
studied
there's a interview with andrew huberman
uh i think he recently did joe rogan
there was a there was one before with
lex friedman
which is the one that i saw and one of
the things that he said that stood out
um which is really really important to
consider
scientific studies and this is
huberman's you know conclusion not mine
obviously but
what they're saying is testosterone
makes effort
feel good okay i'm going to say that
again tea
makes effort feel good when you've got
healthy level
levels of testosterone that's why men
like to compete okay that's why
men are more aggressive that's why you
know men
will take greater risks because it's
because the whole point of having higher
serum concentrations of testosterone
in the male body which is something like
10 to 20 times higher than what women
generally have i mean women also produce
uh testosterone just with much smaller
levels but
the whole point of it is to make effort
feel good okay
so i'll let that you know speak for
itself
i would definitely watch those
interviews because they're really
interesting and
some of the data um will certainly
enlighten a lot of you guys
so pay attention that uh oh yeah thanks
infamous racist traumatic brain injury
so
that's that's one thing that uh can lead
to it
other ones are um like blunt trauma to
your
uh testy so my buddy uh jay campbell who
i've had on several times on my channel
um you can check out his his work i mean
he's talk a lot about
trt or t.o.t is what he called it
um he basically was a professional
basketball player and he and he took a
i don't know a swift kick to the nuts or
something like that and his testosterone
production shut down in his early 30s
and he didn't know what was going on he
felt depressed low energy like all the
standard
symptoms right and then they were
testing his uh blood serum levels they
found that his t
was low and he went on trt in his early
30s because his gonads basically stopped
working so
um there's any number of things that can
affect your body's own endocrine system
from producing it one of the things i
will say there's a book by
a guy called dr anthony j and all you
guys should read this book i've
mentioned it many times on my channel if
you're new
hi read this book it's called estro
generation
uh if you go to any of my recent videos
pinned in the top comment included this
one once it renders
uh there's a link to my amazon bookstore
where the books that i recommend
estrogen estro generation is in there
it's a well-researched book i have an
interview on my channel with dr anthony
j on the plane to win list you can look
that up as well
just type in anthony j uh entrepreneurs
and cars and you'll see the video
pop up but um there's a lot of
environmental estrogens which come
our way which really mess with our
endocrine system like the subtitle of
his book is why
you're sick fat and infertile so
people are having a hard time consult
you know conceiving children if you
haven't noticed
the vast majority of the north north
american population is obese or morbidly
obese
it's a problem and if you're running
very high levels of estrogen in your
body because environmental factors
things like
toiletries sunscreens
water um like tap water for example has
estrogen in it because women on birth
control
when they pee that hormone leaves their
body it goes through the water supply
system
they clean out particles toilet paper
feces
like the standard stuff and they put it
back through the pipes you can't filter
out hormones
so all that peeing from women on birth
control
is going back into the water supply and
we're all drinking it and if you're not
properly filtering your water with a
five stage
water filtration system guess what
fellas you're drinking estrogen
okay there's a lot of environmental
factors even things like
wi-fi bluetooth cellular towers
it's all been proven to disrupt the
mitochondria production and
operation in your testes which means
you're going to suffer with your
testosterone levels
and you're probably going to have higher
levels of estrogen so there's all kinds
of things out there that affect that
read dr anthony j's ester generation for
more on that
you